two degrees is the target for limiting
the global temperature increase but if
greenhouse gas emissions were halted now
temperatures would still rise by up to 1
degrees Celsius
6,000 years ago temperatures were at
this level and America's Midwest was a
desert the world's food production
centres will become barren again in this
future mountains lose their glaciers and
rivers vanish the Indian subcontinent
fighting for survival a single degree
temperature increase could eliminate
fresh water for 1/3 of the planet within
85 years warming at the poles happens
faster than the global average 40
percent of Arctic sea ice has
disappeared in the last 30 years while
ice reflects heat oceans absorb it so as
ice melts the process becomes
self-reinforcing more ocean surface
means more heat absorbed which raises
temperatures making ice less likely to
reform mountainous regions are at
greater risk of landslides as the
permafrost which held them together for
thousands of years melts away low-lying
countries like the Maldives are
submerged as sea levels rise and
countries already hit by hurricanes face
ever greater storms at a 2 degree rise
people begin to die in what are now
considered normal summers in 2003 with
temperatures 2.3 degrees above average
52 thousand people died across Europe
plant growth slows down then stops they
don't absorb carbon dioxide as
efficiently instead emitting it the
extra carbon sees global warming
spiraled out of control
125,000 years ago when temperatures were
2 degrees higher sea levels were up by 6
meters today that extra water makes up
our polar ice which is melting by the
year 2100 sea levels could rise by a
metre displacing 10% of the world's
population
in this two degree future ecosystems
across the globe collapsed as species
migrate and fall out of sync a third of
all life on Earth faces extinction
scientists say we can still avoid a two
degree rise if we limit our carbon
emissions to no more than two point nine
trillion tons we've already used one
point nine trillion tons we have one
trillion left to use between now and
forever
at the current rate we'll use it in just
21 years